[Música]
en el siglo antes de cristo durante la
invasión de termópilas 300 soldados
espartanos aguantaron estoicamente
durante días el ataque de unos 200.000
soldados persas
hoy 2500 años después podemos encontrar
un pequeño país con la misma filosofía
de resistencia determinación y
movilización popular
y no por sorprendente que parezca no
estamos hablando de israel
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas tenéis alguna
idea de qué pequeño país podemos estar
hablando
321 vale sí lo sé el factor sorpresa no
es nuestro fuerte porque la respuesta
está básicamente en el propio título de
este vídeo pero bueno había que darle
algo de emoción así que si habéis
acertado en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
singapur
[Música]
y no de cualquier singapur sino de
singapur más desconocido más castrense
intimidante y fuerte casi casi de la
mismísima esparta del siglo 21 así que
sin más preámbulo arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
singapur es un país pequeño muy pequeño
prácticamente diminuto sin embargo a
pesar de tener menos de 6 millones de
habitantes y apenas
730 kilómetros cuadrados una extensión
similar a la de la ciudad de nueva york
y la mitad que otras como londres o la
ciudad de mexico singapur es toda una
potencia militar
sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien hablamos
de una potencia militar de primer orden
que por sí misma sería capaz de hacer
frente a casi cualquier país del mundo
porque amigos singapur tiene una de las
fuerzas armadas mejor dotadas de todo el
mundo
las fuerzas armadas de singapur cuentan
con algo más de 70 mil efectivos
profesionales a tiempo completo unos
400.000 efectivos a tiempo parcial y más
de 1,2 millones de reservistas con
formación militar porque si en singapur
existe un servicio militar obligatorio
para todos los hombres de 2 años de
duración es el llamado n s de esta forma
las fuerzas armadas regulares ya sea a
tiempo completo o parcial suponen casi
el 8 por ciento de toda la población del
país al tiempo que la población
entrenada militarmente y disponible
representa casi una cuarta parte de
todos los habitantes de esta
ciudad-estado
y ahí no termina todo incluso desde el
año 2015 este país también cuenta con un
ejército de voluntarios el conocido como
cuerpo de voluntarios de las fuerzas
armadas de singapur un cuerpo que
también está abierto a las mujeres y
cuya edad de pertenencia se eleva hasta
los 45 años
[Música]
probablemente en ningún otro país del
mundo la población esté tan involucrada
en las fuerzas armadas pero están
tranquilos porque no hemos hecho más que
empezar como todos seguramente ya sabéis
en la guerra moderna la cantidad de
soldados disponibles no es el elemento
más importante para lograr una victoria
[Música]
por encima del número de efectivos está
la tecnología disponible y el
equipamiento militar algo en lo que
singapur uno de los países más ricos del
mundo tampoco ha escatimado durante las
últimas décadas
por ejemplo singapur tiene más aviones
de combate que las fuerzas aéreas de
países como canadá suecia o países bajos
en capacidades e incluso por encima de
las fuerzas aéreas de países como españa
y es que hablamos de equipos avanzados
adquiridos a la industria militar de
eeuu israel y europa de hecho singapur
ha sido el primer país del todo el
sudeste asiático en hacerse con
alcanzado de quinta generación efe 35
evidentemente tal y como os podéis
imaginar el presupuesto militar de este
país no es precisamente pequeño sobre
todo si tenemos en cuenta que se trata
de una ciudad de estado con menos de 6
millones de habitantes
pues bien en 2021 el gasto militar de
esta ciudad superó los 11 mil 500
millones de dólares lo que supone casi
el triple que el presupuesto militar de
su vecino malasia y un 25 por ciento más
que el gasto militar de indonesia un
país que tiene 46 veces más habitantes
para que solo es una idea hablamos de un
presupuesto similar al de un lugar tan
amenazado como taiwán no os resulta
sorprendente
singapur es un territorio muy rico y con
mucha seguridad jurídica uno de los
enclaves donde van a parar los capitales
de millones de inversores y empresas de
todo el mundo un estatus que necesita
protección y con los datos en la mano
parece que lo tienen muy pero que muy
claro
el caso es que desde que lograra su
independencia en
1965 este pequeño país asiático ha
tenido tres grandes estrategias
militares tres grandes estrategias
militares que explican su percepción del
mundo y que con el paso de los años han
todo forma a sus relativamente enormes y
bien equipadas fuerzas armadas
[Música]
porque amigos amigas nada de lo que os
hemos contado es casual acentos esto un
momento antes de continuar
[Música]
en visual política hablamos mucho de
china pero sabíais que el país está
atravesando un difícil momento económico
se había es que china podría estar
enfrentándose a uno de los mayores retos
en sus más de 40 años de apertura
económica queridos amigos amigas china
ha experimentado un despegue
inmobiliario de tal calibre durante las
últimas décadas que lo miremos por donde
lo miremos ha inflado una gigantesca
burbuja que hoy podría estar a punto de
estallar ahora bien quieres saber más
sobre lo que está ocurriendo en china a
qué riesgo se enfrenta este país y qué
consecuencias podría tener pues no os
perdáis el último vídeo de si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de mutuactivos con el que
colaboramos os dejamos el enlace en la
descripción pero dicho esto continuemos
[Música]
envenenada
la primera estrategia militar la gran
estrategia de defensa de singapur llegó
poco después de su independencia de la
mano del célebre lee kuan yew el
histórico primer ministro que diseñó el
actual singapur y que gobernó durante 20
años el caso es que tras separarse del
reino unido- integrarse en malasia y ser
expulsado en apenas dos años lee kuan
yew tuvo muy claro que para poder
sobrevivir singapur tenía que
convertirse en un lugar que nadie
quisiera invadir una idea que plasmó en
1966 de forma muy clara en una de sus
citas más conocidas en un mundo en el
que el pez grande se come al pequeño y
el pequeño como gambas singapur tiene
que convertirse en una gamba envenenada
si te la comes tendrás problemas
digestivos lee kuan yew cuando lee kuan
yew pronuncia estas palabras la
situación de singapur era radicalmente
distinta a su estatus actual en aquel
momento singapur era un país pobre sin
apenas aliados rodeado de vecinos algo
hostiles que tenía que sobrevivir en un
mundo partido en dos singapur tenía que
ser capaz
por si mismo el objetivo era que invadir
este enclave se volviera una operación
tan costosa en términos de dinero vida y
recursos militares que ningún otro país
tuviera la tentación de hacerlo la
defensa de singapur tenía que ser capaz
de infligir el mayor daño posible al
enemigo incluso si éste lograba invadir
la ciudad si eso ocurría singapur se
convertía en la gamba envenenada
una estrategia por cierto muy similar a
la que muchos analistas defienden que
tiene que adoptar taiwán para defenderse
de china ahora bien la pregunta es cómo
lograr todo esto en la práctica cómo
conseguir convertirse en toda una gamba
envenenada pues bien fundamentalmente
mediante tres vías armándose hasta los
dientes preparándose para el combate y
consiguiendo amigos fuertes
[Música]
cuando singapur se independizó en la
ciudad-estado apenas contaba con dos
batallones de infantería un viejo cañón
y ningún avión de combate había que
construir un ejército prácticamente
desde cero para lograrlo lee kuan yew le
dio a su ministro de interior y de
defensa boquense una orden secreta
singapur tenía que estrechar lazos con
israel egipto y la india
y sabéis que de los 3 la respuesta más
efusiva llegó precisamente de israel un
país desesperado por lograr amigos en el
exterior así que israel no solo fue uno
de los primeros estados en reconocer a
singapur sino que en octubre de
1965 apenas dos meses después de
proclamar su plena independencia el
ejército hebreo ya estaba manos a la
obra ayudando a diseñar las fuerzas
armadas de este nuevo país
claro que la cosa no era tan sencilla la
colaboración entre estos dos países
tenía que ser lo más discreta posible
tan discreta nadie podía enterarse
porque puedes pensar un momento en los
dos países que rodean a la ciudad-estado
malasia e indonesia dos grandes países
musulmanes que en aquella época como
prácticamente todos los países
musulmanes tenían a israel en el punto
de mira así que sí singapur no quería
ser visto como un elemento hostil y
correr el riesgo de justificar una
invasión tenía que tirar de inventiva
fijaos los primeros asesores militares
enviados de israel a singapur fueron
llamados mexicanos por discreción y ojo
porque para hacerlo creíble israel
seleccionó para la operación a miembros
de sus fuerzas armadas cuyos rasgos les
permitirá hacerse pasar por mexicanos
así que nada de soldados y oficiales
rubios o con la piel excesivamente
blanca y ojo que esta anécdota la cuenta
el propio lee kuan yew en sus memorias
publicadas en 1998
[Música]
el caso es que de esta colaboración
salió el llamado libro marrón un plan
maestro capitaneado por el entonces
subdirector de operaciones de la sep de
israelíes rejabam zeevi
quiero que recordéis varias cosas uno no
vamos a convertir a singapur en una
colonia israelí vuestra tarea es
enseñarles la profesión militar ponerlos
de pie para que puedan dirigir su propio
ejército en segundo lugar no vais allí
para dirigirlos sino para aconsejarlos y
tercero no sois comerciantes de armas
cuando recomendáis equipamiento para
adquirir utilizar el más puro criterio
militar profesional github ravin antiguo
primer ministro de israel
de esta forma en apenas tres meses los
israelíes crearon toda una estrategia y
doctrina militar cuyo eje central era
construir un ejército ciudadano de
reclutas que fueran entrenados y
dirigidos por una pequeña fuerza regular
muy profesional y bien equipada os
recuerda algo esta estructura exacto es
exactamente el mismo modelo que continúa
en vigor hoy en día
[Música]
pues bien el caso es que para lograr
este objetivo y conseguir que el país
tuviera 12 batallones listos para
defender la ciudad en menos de una
década fue por lo que se estableció el
servicio militar obligatorio
la idea básicamente era lograr que toda
la nación pudiera movilizarse en caso de
ser necesario y que esa enorme capacidad
fuera el gran bastión de la defensa de
la ciudad pero claro a medida que el
país se fue enriqueciendo y las fuerzas
armadas lograron estar más equipadas y
mejor entrenadas se hizo evidente que
hacía falta actualizar la estrategia
militar pues bien ese momento llegó con
la década de los 80 a partir de ese
momento la visión militar de singapur
evolucionó hasta que ver convertirse en
toda una gran potencia militar atentos
porque es pines y delfines singapur ya
está aquí
década y media ese fue todo el tiempo
que le llevó a singapur pasar de ser una
empobrecida colonia de pescadores sin
ejército a estar en condiciones de
actuar militarmente fuera de sus propios
límites territoriales y en esto se basó
precisamente la segunda estrategia
militar singapurense la conocida como la
estrategia del puercoespín que empezó a
aplicarse a principios de los 80 y que
supuso un enorme cambio singapur ya no
tenía la necesidad de asumir de aceptar
que podía terminar siendo invadido
aunque fuera a un alto coste que era
básicamente lo que planteaba la idea de
la gamba envenenada ahora ya tenían la
formación y el equipamiento suficiente
para convertir su modelo de defensa
pasiva en otro mucho más activo esta
doctrina estuvo en vigor hasta la
llegada del nuevo siglo y supuso el paso
necesario para terminar de construir un
ejército moderno
siguiendo la doctrina del puercoespín
singapur no sólo se convirtió en un
importante cliente de la industria
militar norteamericana e israelí europea
lo que de por sí le daba una enorme
influencia sino que también desarrolló
su propia industria local de equipos
militares una industria que le ha
permitido a singapur convertirse en uno
de los 30 mayores exportadores de armas
por volumen de todo el mundo entre sus
equipos con más éxito podemos destacar
el rifle de asalto usar 21 el
todoterreno militar bronco o el blindado
de transporte terrestre así como un
montón de drones y obuses de todo tipo
pero aquí no termina todo actualmente
singapore aplica su tercera gran
estrategia la conocida como doctrina del
delfín gamba puercoespín delfín esto va
de animales pero bueno porque el delfín
pues veréis el delfín es un animal
tremendamente ágil que es capaz de
utilizar esta agilidad incluso para
atacar a tiburones a pesar de no ser tan
fuertes como ellos y esa es precisamente
la idea bajo esta doctrina singapur está
construyendo una fuerza aérea
impresionante muy fuerte muy ágil capaz
de anticiparse a cualquier amenaza es
decir lograr la total superioridad aérea
en la región para lograr este enorme
poder de respuesta y anticipación el
actual primer ministro lee sin luz ha
puesto en marcha un ambicioso plan para
adaptar toda la estructura militar a
esta nueva misión
entre las claves de la nueva estrategia
está la sustitución de la antigua flota
de f-16 por los f 35b de quinta
generación así como la renovación y
ampliación de la flota de su armada que
actualmente opera seis fragatas
multimisión basadas en la clase
lafayette francesa también destaca la
adquisición de armas clave como los
tanques leopard de segunda generación
alemanes los vehículos autóctonos de
combate hunter en servicio desde 2019 o
el lanzamisiles estadounidense lockheed
martin m 142 hi macs de los que singapur
cuenta ya con dos docenas de unidades
de esta forma es como singapur se
convirtió primero en una ciudad
militarizada luego en una fortaleza
inexpugnable y ahora en un actor militar
capaz de aplicar aquella máxima que dice
que he llegado el caso la mejor defensa
puede ser un buen ataque
[Música]
pero un momento porque no todo pasa por
el arsenal singapur lleva muchos años
potenciando las sinergias militares con
sus aliados en especial a través del
entrenamiento militar actualmente los
soldados de singapur se entrenan en
países tan dispares como eeuu australia
tailandia taiwán o sudáfrica y
frecuentemente participan en ejercicios
militares defensivos a gran escala
además singapur también ha sellado
importantes acuerdos de defensa con el
'tío sam' acuerdos que incluyen el
acceso a bases militares singapurenses
de los soldados norteamericanos
singapur renueva el pacto de bases
militares con eeuu en mitad de la
profundización de los lazos de defensa
frente a china washington renovó el
acuerdo garantizando el acceso de las
fuerzas norteamericanas a las bases de
la ciudad del león hasta 2035 subrayando
la importancia de la ciudad para la
estrategia de eeuu en asia
armadas de 21 países inician ejercicios
liderados por eeuu en el sudeste
asiático los ejercicios se acate están
en marcha en singapur al tiempo que
virtualmente pekín y moscú también
llevan a cabo ejercicios en knicks ya
china claro que un momento esto no
quiere decir que singapur sea un actor
beligerante no para nada una cosa es
llevarse bien con eeuu y otra muy
distinta llevarse mal con china ya que
singapur juega digamos con una cierta
ventaja el 69% de los chinos tiene una
buena imagen de esta cita de estado cuyo
modelo el mismísimo den xiaoping tomó
como ejemplo para poner en marcha las
reformas que han construido la china de
hoy
singapur es algo así como la combinación
entre la vocación militar de esparta y
la histórica neutralidad suiza esta
querida comunidad de visual política es
una gran plaza financiera un refugio
para capitales y negocios de todo el
mundo para ello tanto la fuerza como la
vocación de neutralidad juegan un papel
clave sea como sea esta es la cara menos
conocida de singapur su rol como toda
una potencia militar a pesar de tener
menos de 6 millones de habitantes y
menos de la mitad de superficie que la
ciudad de londres ahora si este vídeo os
ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle al botón de like i suscribiros
avisar politics si aún no lo habéis
hecho muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]